la séance est ouverte
le contrôle de analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation le
procès-verbal est donc adopté sur les
réserves d'usage
je ne vois pas d'observation séance
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée de proposer un texte
commun sur le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 je vais immédiatement
donner la parole à Madame Elisabeth
Doisneau rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales chers collègues la
commission mixte paritaire réunis hier
pour examiner les dispositions restants
en discussion de ce projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale 2023 a réussi à établir un texte
commun
lors de ces travaux René Paul Savary et
moi-même avons veillé à rester fidèle à
l'esprit de la majorité sénatoriale
cette réforme dont nous savons demandera
des efforts aux Français doit atteindre
pleinement son but ramener notre système
de retraite à l'équilibre à l'horizon de
2030 afin de garantir sa soutenabilité
financière au bénéfice des générations
futures
c'est en ayant cet objectif en tête que
tout en s'inscrivant tout en inscrivant
ces marqueurs dans le texte le Sénat a
veillé en première lecture à rester dans
une épure financière proche de
l'équilibre
René Paul Savary vous détaillera
certains choix de la CMP qui se
traduiront par des coûts supplémentaires
pour le système de retraite par rapport
à la version du texte adopté par le
Sénat
néanmoins messieurs les ministres
j'espère que vous serez en mesure de
nous confirmer que le texte issu de la
commission mixte paritaire permet le
retour à l'équilibre des comptes en 2030
moyennant peut-être un nouvel ajustement
des taux de cotisation patronales
vieillesse et ATMP
en toute état de cause mes chers
collègues vous retrouverez dans le texte
qui vous est présenté les principales
mesures que nous avons examinées
et adopter tout au long de la semaine
dernière et même pour certaines depuis
plusieurs années dans le cadre des PLFSS
je pense naturellement au décalage
progressif de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
ainsi qu'à l'accélération de la réforme
Touraine sur lesquelles reposent
l'équilibre financier de ce PLFR SS je
pense aussi à la mise en extension
extinction des principaux régimes
spéciaux avec la clause dite du
grand-père au terme de laquelle les
personnes embauchées à compter du 1er
septembre 2023 dans les entreprises et
institutions concernées seront affiliés
au régime général pour le risque
vieillesse
je pense également à l'abandon du projet
de transfert aux URSSAF de l'activité de
recouvrement de l'agir Carco et de la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations qui a
été confirmé par la CMP
enfin je vous précise que la CMP a
confirmé l'introduction dans l'annexea
du principe de compensation intégrale
par l'état des 2023 des surcos engendrés
par la hausse de cotisations patronale
cnr-cl pour les employeurs publics
concernés
du fait du maintien de ses nombreux
marqueurs du Sénat et avec les autres
dispositions qui vont vous être
présentés par René Paul Savary je vous
appelle mes chers collègues à approuvé
les conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire et je vous remercie de votre
attention merci madame le rapporteur
général
de donner la parole à notre collègue
René Paul Savary rapporteur pour le
Sénat de la commission mixte paritaire
[Applaudissements]
très rapidement quelques minutes pour
vous rapporter cette commission mix
paritaire particulière compte tenu que
l'Assemblée nationale a été empêché de
débattre et de voter il appartenait
justement de recréer le débat au sein de
cette commission mix paritaire 9h 9h
dans lequel il y a eu des avancées un
compromis trouvé entre les exigences du
Sénat à travers des mesures auxquelles
nous étions particulièrement attachés en
ce qui concerne par exemple les maires
de famille en ce qui concerne l'usure
professionnelle cette pâte du Sénat
était importante merci Monsieur le
Ministre également d'avoir accordé pour
l'employabilité des seniors d'avoir
accordé le fait de créer une un accord
national interprofessionnel sur l'emploi
des seniors demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée c'est important c'est comme
ça que nous pourrons réussir il
appartenait également de prendre en
compte des avancées de la et des
propositions de l'Assemblée nationale
qui n'avaient plus être débattu jusqu'au
bout
notamment en ce qui concerne les
carrières longues pour lesquelles il y a
une avancée significative avec les 25
ans les 43 annuités minimum pour les
bornes d'âge qui permettront à certains
véritablement d'être pris en compte dans
la durée de cotisation c'est une avancée
importante et c'est le fruit de cette
réflexion qui a fait en sorte que nous
puissions je pense voter sans état d'âme
cette réforme qui a été particulièrement
adoucie par rapport aux mesures
proposées directement par le
gouvernement et qui fait que nous avons
pris en compte les difficultés notamment
exprimées à travers l'usure
professionnelle nous y sommes attachés
et c'est la raison pour laquelle les
mesures de Sénat ayant été en grande
partie reprise dans le texte final je
vous invite mes chers collègues à voter
cette réforme
merci monsieur le rapporteur
je vais maintenant donner la parole
au ministre du Travail du plein emploi
de l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du somme
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
madame la monsieur le rapporteur madame
le rapporteur pour avis un accord à
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs un
accord a donc été trouvé un accord entre
les deux assemblées qui ont su se
retrouver sur l'essentiel autour de
cette réforme des retraites un accord
qui réaffirme sans ambiguïté
l'attachement de la représentation de la
représentation nationale à notre système
par répartition
hérité de la prière un accord enfin qui
permet de mettre voix un texte
profondément enrichi après plusieurs
semaines de débats parlementaire le
texte qui est soumis au vote de vos deux
assemblées conjugue le cœur de la
réforme du président de la République le
Kurt ses engagements avec de nombreuses
améliorations portées par les
parlementaires dans les deux chambres
ainsi les engagements pris au printemps
dernier devant les Français sont tenus
il s'agit de travailler progressivement
plus pour équilibrer notre système de
retraite il s'agissait aussi de fermer
les principaux régimes spéciaux dans le
respect de la clause dite du grand-père
s'assurer aussi
augmenter la retraite minimale pour une
carrière complète je crois ainsi pouvoir
dire que ce texte est aussi pouvoir dire
ce texte est profondément enrichi jour
après jour et au fil de la discussion
ainsi et grâce à votre soutien nous
avons concrétisé des demandes de longue
date par exemple pour les sapeurs
pompiers volontaires pour les apprentis
les stagiaires les étudiants les
sportifs ou encore les enseignants du
primaire et je suis certain que
plusieurs améliorations renforceront
durablement la justice de notre système
de retraite sachant qu'il est bien
évidemment je n'ai pas été exhaustif
dans la liste que je viens de faire il
est difficile quand on présente et quand
on commente les résultats d'une
commission mixte paritaire d'éviter
l'effet d'inventaire mais je suis
convaincu que chaque avancée compte et
mérite d'être reconnu en tant que tel je
pense notamment à la création d'une
surcote avant l'âge légal pour les mers
qui ont atteint la durée d'affiliation
requise avant c'est atteinte de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits je pense à
l'instauration du CDI senior portait
avec force et convictions par votre
apporteur René Paul Savary tout en
assurant le renvoie à leur titre L1 du
Code du travail cher président du Sénat
je pense la création d'une pension de
réversion pour les orphelins en
particulier selon situation de handicap
c'est à l'initiative du Président rotaïo
je pense à la prise en compte des
parents confrontés au deuil d'un enfant
à l'initiative des groupes CRCE RDP ou
encore écologiste je pense à la perte
des droits familiaux pour les parents
violents sur proposition de la
présidente billon je pense on va
forcément des droits à la retraite des
élus locaux portez ici notamment par les
rapporteur pour avis Sylvie vermillier
ou encore à la revalorisation des
pensions à Mayotte à l'initiative de
votre collègue Dany Mohamed suadi ainsi
que du président Hervé Marseille au
total si tu me livre à cette inventaire
c'est pour montrer que le texte a été
enrichi que le texte est amélioré au fil
des discussions et je crois aussi qu'il
peut montrer que ce texte correspond à
l'équilibre politique qui résulte des
travaux qui ont été les vôtres
cet équilibre il doit être aussi
financier parce que demander un effort
financier et laisser fidéliser déficit
serait injuste et irresponsable et donc
nous maintiendrons l'équilibre du
système de retraite à l'horizon 2030 tel
que prévu par le texte initial c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans un premier
temps le gouvernement lève le gage pour
les gages restants l'article 2 bis A et
l'article 8 et c'est surtout la raison
pour laquelle nous prévoyons un
transfert supplémentaire de la branche
ATMP pour assurer financement tout en
laissant cette branche largement
excédentaire mais mon collègue Gabriel
Attal ministre délégué au compte public
il reviendra une fois que je dis cela
bien évidemment je nie pas les
désaccords qui persistent pas plus que
je n'occulte l'expression de
l'opposition à la réforme et je suis sûr
à l'inverse que personne ne contestera
que le débat a bien eu lieu
débat avec les partenaires sociaux après
quatre mois de concertation qui ont
permis de concrétiser des avancées que
personne n'aurait pu imaginer il y a
justement seulement quelques mois je
pense en particulier l'emploi des
seniors à la prévention de la pénibilité
alors que nous pensions les positions
des uns et des autres iraient
conciliables nous avons su je crois les
rapprocher des pas au Parlement aussi
bien évidemment avec 74 heures de
discussions à l'Assemblée nationale et
sans deux heures discussion au Sénat
nous pouvons dire le débat a eu lieu
certains diront que c'est trop peu mais
il faut décrire la réalité telle qu'elle
est cette réforme a été davantage
discutée que les deux précédentes
réformes des retraites cumulées en
termes de temps d'expression et de temps
de débat d'autres sites diront qu'il
reviendront sur cette réforme lorsqu'ils
arriveront un jour au pouvoir mais
qu'avons-nous constater depuis 30 ans
avec autant de réforme de retraite
jamais je dis bien jamais une alternance
politique n'a remise en cause les
efforts demandés par les réformes
précédentes je crois pouvoir dire pour
conclure ce débat devant vous qu'au fond
nous avons suivi un seul fil rouge celui
du débat contradictoire et républicain
l'opposition moins ici qu'ailleurs
peut-être mais l'opposition à choisir
notre fil rouge celui de l'obstruction
méthodique une obstruction qui sacrifie
la mission même d'un parlementaire qui
abîme le débat chaque jour un peu plus
et une obstruction qui aura été assumée
dans une confusion Inuit entre la
légitimité du Parlement et l'expression
de la rue de manœuvre en blocage
d'attaques personnelles en comportement
violent nous avons assisté à une dérive
moins ici qu'ailleurs mais avec la même
volonté d'une obstruction que je trouve
dangereuse
je veux le dire avec gravité devant vous
la République ne doit pas céder un pouce
de terrain c'est dérives et nous les
combattrons jour après jour mes textes
après textes en réalité beaucoup parmi
les opposants ont cité Victor Hugo tout
en foulant parfois aux pieds son sens
aigu du républicanisme qui aurait fait
honneur au débat
le gouvernement a fait un choix et
assume ce choix ce choix c'est celui de
surmonter cette obstruction pour assurer
la clarté et la sincérité des débats
d'abord en prévoyant qu'un amendement ou
un sous amendement n'ayant pas été
examiné par la commission des affaires
sociales ne puisse être présenté devant
le Parlement c'est l'application de
l'article 44 Linéa 2 de la Constitution
ensuite en demandant au Sénat de se
prononcer par un vote unique sur
l'ensemble du texte après présentation
de l'ensemble des amendements par le
retard c'est l'article 44 alinéa 3 de
notre peine constitution certains ont
voulu faire croire à une procédure
inhabituelle voire totalement inédite
mais répéter le même mensonge n'en fait
pas une vérité les choses sont simples
les trois précédentes réforme des
retraites ont eu recours au même vote
unique pour surmonter l'obstruction la
réforme dites Fillon d'examen première
lecture au Sénat fait l'objet d'un vote
unique en juillet 2003 la réforme dites
verte un vote unique a été appliqué en
première lecture au Sénat en octobre
2010 sur un quart des amendements la
réforme dite tourelle enfin un vote
unique a été appliqué en nouvelle
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale en
novembre 2013 et hors réforme des
retraites je ne mentionnerai évidemment
pas les nombreux autres uniques qui ont
eu lieu ici au Sénat sur des projets de
loi de finances des projets de loi de
financement rectificatifs des projets de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale ou encore des lois ordinaires
comme la loi de sécurisation de l'emploi
au début de l'année 2013 alors oui pour
mettre fin à la négation du
parlementarisme garantir la clarté du
débat le gouvernement a bien eu recours
alors l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution et ce neuvième jour de
ralentissement voir des blocages et
débats avant que le texte puisse être
mise au vote dans sa totalité et adopter
je l'espère par votre assemblée je
souhaite vous dire que et j'espère avec
vous que nous pourrons ainsi achever
cette navette parlementaire c'est aussi
rappeler que cette réforme s'inscrit
dans un objectif plus large fixé par le
président de la République au cœur de ma
feuille de route celui du plein emploi
il suppose de mobilier tous les de
mobiliser tous les leviers à notre
disposition pour y parvenir nous l'avons
fait il y a quelques mois avec
l'assurance chômage nous le faisons avec
les retraites nous allons faire surtout
avec le projet de loi pour le travail et
le plein emploi qui viendra dans
quelques semaines devant vous autour de
sujets cruciaux comme la mise en place
de France travail le compte est
important universel le partage de la
valeur la suite des Assises du travail
en matière de conditions et de qualité
de vie au travail mais aussi de nombreux
sujets permettant à la fois d'aller vers
le plein emploi et de faire en sorte que
ce plein emploi soit aussi un bon emploi
merci pour votre travail merci pour
votre attention et je l'espère à bientôt
pour de nouveaux textes et de nouveaux
débats
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
donner la parole maintenant au ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
monsieur Gabriel Attal
la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous sommes face à un vote qui
conditionnera les 15 prochaines années
de la vie de notre pays et du quotidien
de nos concitoyens un vote pour une
génération dans le vote que vous vous
apprêtez à faire il y a l'avenir de
toute une génération celle qui travaille
et qui souhaitent garder son mode de vie
une fois arrivé au bout d'une vie de
labeur à la retraite dans le vote que
vous vous apprêtez à faire il y a aussi
tout ce qui fait notre pays son modèle
social sa vie politique et parlementaire
la cohérence des valeurs politiques
défendues par les représentants du
peuple sa capacité à aller de l'avant
mais aussi un choix profond entre le
travail et l'impôt
le vote que vous apprêtez à faire ne
vient pas seulement trancher un débat
politique et médiatique de plusieurs
mois il n'est pas simplement le point
final d'une séquence difficile qui je
suis parfaitement lucide à angoisser et
parfois divisé notre pays ce vote il est
aussi il est surtout la réponse à des
questions aussi fondamentales que ces
trois questions là que je pose devant
vous ce matin
voulons-nous oui ou non garantir à
bientôt 20 millions de retraités qui
pourront compter sereinement sur une
retraite financée afin de pouvoir
préserver leur mode de vie qu'ils n'ont
aucune envie de sacrifier pensons-nous
que c'est le travail qui entraîne la
prospérité d'une nation ou bien que
c'est l'impôt qui crée la richesse
les valeurs et le projet pour lesquelles
les Français ont élu leur représentants
au Parlement
doivent-ils être défendus par leur
parlementaire au risque sinon d'une
fissure encore plus profonde de la
confiance entre le peuple et ses élus
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
pourrai ma pesantir sur les réponses que
le gouvernement souhaite apporter à ces
questions je pourrais vous redire que
l'unique raison pour laquelle nous
faisons cette réforme c'est pour
préserver le patrimoine de ceux qui
n'ont que leur travail pour vivre et
pouvoir simplement leur dire sereinement
les yeux dans les yeux vos pensions ne
baisseront pas vos salaires ne
diminueront pas vos impôts
n'augmenteront pas
je pourrais vous dire aussi que la
réponse du gouvernement au choix entre
le travail et plus d'impôts et clair
c'est le travail qui crée la richesse
pas les impôts supplémentaires et que ce
choix nous guide nous oblige et que ce
choix du travail sur l'impôt c'est
certes le choix de l'effort mais c'est
surtout le choix de la prospérité et je
pourrais vous dire enfin que oui le
respect des engagements pris devant les
Français est au cœur du pacte entre le
peuple et ses représentants mais ce
n'est pas à vous ce n'est pas au Sénat
que j'ai besoin de le dire vous avez
toujours respecté vos engagements ce qui
se joue aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui en décide ce sont les
représentants du peuple par leur vote
votre vote c'est la démocratie cette
démocratie à la fois encadrée et
garantie par notre Constitution sans
laquelle rien n'est légitime
car notre Constitution c'est le cœur
même du pacte entre les Français et
leurs élus ce pacte qui existe depuis
que la France et les Français votent ce
pacte qui a permis des avancées majeures
pour les Français ce pacte qui a
conforté à plusieurs reprises la
démocratie lorsqu'elle va s'y est et que
ces institutions ne parvenaient plus à
œuvrer pour le payer voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire dès le début de mon
intervention comme marque de respect à
la fois pour le Parlement et pour le
Sénat je le disais mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ma conviction c'est que
c'est le travail qui crée la prospérité
et que c'est donc par le travail que
nous devons financer les évolutions de
notre modèle social l'une des évolutions
majeures auxquelles notre pays est
soumis c'est sa démographie les faits
sont implacables notre pays vieillit
notre pays comptera plus de retraités
qu'il n'en a jamais compté notre modèle
social devra donc financer plus de
retraite que jamais
en 2030 nous aurons à payer chaque mois
la retraite de 20 millions de retraités
c'est un quasi doublement en une
génération il y avait 12 millions de
pensions de retraite à payer chaque mois
au début des années 2000 aucun pays ne
pourrait tenir ce choc sans rien faire
et d'ailleurs presque tous les pays
autour de nous réforme où on réformé
leur retraite et nous notre choix c'est
de le réformer par le travail oui c'est
un effort mais non il ne sera pas porté
par tous de la même manière
indifféremment quatre Français sur 10
partiront à la retraite avant bien avant
l'âge légal mais 10 Français sur 10
pourront continuer à bénéficier d'une
retraite sans hausse d'impôts ni baisse
de pension l'autre choix qui a émergé au
cours de plus de 200 heures de débats à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat c'est
celui de l'impôt des cotisations
l'impôt toujours l'impôt tout le temps
l'impôt pour tous taxer taxé voilà
l'autre projet qui a émergé ce projet-là
nous l'avons combattu par les idées et
je remercie la majorité sénatoriale
d'avoir contribué à le repousser non pas
par idéologie je le sais mais par bon
sens qui serait les premières victimes
des hausses d'impôts les Français qui
travaillent dur qui se lèvent le matin
qui font vivre leur famille et tourner
le pays
taxer les plus riches taxés les grands
groupes cela peut toujours être
séduisant
mais l'impôt de trop ça commence par
taxer ce qui sont en haut et ça finit
par frapper ceux qui sont en bas
voilà pourquoi avec la majorité
sénatoriale nous avons repoussé avec
détermination toute tentative d'impôts
ou dose de cotisation en plus voilà
pourquoi ce texte se fonde sur des
valeurs communes le travail comme
condition de la prospérité et la
retraite comme au raison bien mérité
d'une vie de travail voilà pourquoi je
le dis le texte qui vous est soumis
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est aussi le vôtre cette réforme des
retraites c'est aussi celle du Sénat et
des sénateurs ce texte est aussi le dos
le vôtre parce que je l'ai dit il prend
ses racines dans des valeurs communes le
travail la préservation de notre modèle
social le refus de tout impôt
supplémentaire ce texte est aussi le
vôtre parce qu'en première lecture vous
l'avez voté et vous l'avez adopté ce
texte est aussi le vôtre parce qu'il est
le fruit d'un compromis politique
construit patiemment au fil de
l'élaboration de ce texte de sa
discussion et de son vote en commission
puis en séance publique et maintenant au
cours de la commission mixte paritaire
qui a eu lieu hier c'est compromis
permettent des avancées importantes ces
compromis ont à bouté abouti à des
avancées que les Français devront aussi
à cette majorité sénatoriale je pense
notamment et je le souligne d'autant
plus que je m'y étais opposé monsieur le
rapporteur à l'expérimentation d'un CDI
senior avec un dispositif recentré sur
les demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée
expérimentées sur plusieurs années c'est
je le sais une idée à laquelle les
rapporteurs étaient particulièrement
attachés comme d'ailleurs la majorité
sénatoriale c'est dans le texte que nous
vous proposons de voter je pense aussi
au compromis trouvé sur le sujet des
carrières longues avec la reprise du
dispositif proposé par le groupe LR à
l'Assemblée nationale
je précise toutefois que nous avons eu
des discussions nourries pour affiner ce
dispositif enfin je veux dire un mot du
dispositif de surcotte pour les maires
de famille introduit par la commission
des affaires sociales du Sénat et qui a
bien sûr été intégré à l'accord trouvé
hier c'est un apport majeur du Sénat qui
permettra aux femmes de bénéficier d'une
pension revalorisée jusqu'à 5% au titre
des trimestres liés à la naissance d'un
enfant ou de leur éducation les derniers
ajustements actés hier durant la CMP
bien sûr faire l'objet d'une traduction
financière c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement a déposé un amendement
de chiffres à l'article 6 qui actualise
l'annexe A du texte c'est-à-dire la
trajectoire financière pluriannuelle des
régimes de sécurité sociale mais je
réponds à Madame la rapporteur général
qui a posé la question oui à l'issue de
la CMP et à travers un nouveau transfert
de taux entre la branche ATMP et la
branche vieillesse l'équilibre de notre
système de retraite en 2030 et garantie
par le travail travail du Parlement et
par le compromis qui a été trouvé hier
en commission mixte paritaire voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs ce
que je voulais vous dire alors que vous
vous apprêtez à voter une réforme
importante pour l'avenir de notre pays
et pour le mode de vie des Français et
de nos retraités si je devais résumer en
ce moment en trois mots je dirais que
nous sommes à un rendez-vous celui de
nos institutions celui de notre modèle
social et celui de notre prospérité
celui de nos institutions car elle
garantissent que notre pays peut
continuer à avancer et bien nos
institutions c'est vous c'est le Sénat
c'est le Parlement tout le Parlement
rien que le Parlement nous institutions
c'est notre Constitution toute notre
Constitution rien que notre Constitution
celui de notre modèle social car là
aussi rappelons-nous que nous sommes les
lointains héritiers nous au gouvernement
vous sur ces bancs des hommes et des
femmes politiques qui ont eu le génie et
la générosité d'inventer notre modèle
social et qu'en être les héritiers cela
veut dire tout faire pour le perpétuer
et lui permettre de durer dans le temps
celui de notre prospérité enfin car le
choix que nous faisons est clair créer
de la richesse par l'activité pas par la
fiscalité aller de l'avant par davantage
de travail pas par davantage d'impôts
nous sommes au rendez-vous de nos
institutions de notre modèle social et
de notre prospérité mais s'il est un
rendez-vous qui compte par dessus tout
un rendez-vous que nous devons pas
manquer c'est celui de nos compatriotes
les Français ceux qui travaillent et qui
veulent continuer à faire vivre leur
famille à faire tourner leur pays sans
outrance et sans blocage ce qui
travaille et qui veulent continuer à
penser à la retraite comme un temps bien
mérité de leur vie on récolte enfin
sereinement le fruit d'une vie de
travail ce rendez-vous celui des
promesses que nous avons faites aux
Français celui des engagements que nous
avons pris et que nous devons tenir ce
rendez-vous il est maintenant alors
votons ce texte pour continuer à aller
de l'avant je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle
qu'en application de l'article 42 aligné
à 12 du règlement le Sénat étant appelé
à se prononcer avant l'Assemblée
nationale il statue sur les éventuels
amendements puis par un seul vote sur
l'ensemble du texte
en conséquence
d'amendement déposé par le Gouvernement
sera mis au voie puis le vote sur
l'article sera réservé nous passerons
ensuite aux explications de vote et au
vote sur l'ensemble
nous allons passer à la présentation de
l'amendement du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre je vais vous donner la parole
merci monsieur le Président comme je
viens de l'indiquer dans mon
intervention il s'agit d'un amendement
qui modifie l'annexe obligatoire
prévisible présentant les prévisions de
recettes les objectifs de dépenses et le
tableau d'équilibre par branche des
régimes obligatoires de base pour les
années à venir c'est un amendement de
coordination qui permet de tenir compte
en conformité avec le principe de
sincérité des lois financières des
impacts financiers des amendements
adoptés au Sénat et des modifications
issues de la CMP
que quelle est l'avis de la commission
madame la rapporteur général
alors la commission de séparer
ré une ni trop personnel j'apporte un
avis favorable parce que c'est un
principe de sincérité et c'est la
traduction des accords qui ont été
trouvés hier en CMP et aussi des votes
du Sénat donc
c'est un avis favorable
bien
l'amendement va être distribué
l'amendement est aussi consultable en
ligne
voilà
pourquoi on
qu'est-ce qu'il faut demander
commandement tire les conséquences du
vote du Sénat du vote de la commission
mixte paritaire
madame la Présidente de la Commission et
ensuite un rappel au règlement
merci monsieur le Président en effet
monsieur le ministre nous découvrons
cette amendement ce matin qu'en fait la
correction du tableau lié au conclusions
de la commission mix paritaire si vous
voulez bien m'écouter je rappelle que
les conclusions de la commission tout le
monde les connaît et bien évidemment
elles ont une incidence sur le tableau
ça c'est indéniable c'est ce que nous
voyons mais si vous souhaitez que la
commission se prononce officiellement je
vous propose de nous réunir quelques
minutes dans la au salon Victor Hugo
pour examiner le tableau
le ministre
et ensuite madame Cohen
oui merci monsieur le Président
simplement pour préciser c'est un moment
qui est long puisqu'il reprend
l'intégralité de l'annexe A mais en
réalité il y a une modification par
rapport au texte initial c'est un
nouveau transfert de recettes entre la
branche ATMP et la branche vieillesse
pour garantir l'équilibre de notre
système comme je l'ai annoncé dans mon
intervention de 700 millions d'euros de
700 millions d'euros ce qui garantit
l'équilibre de notre système de retraite
c'est la seule évolution notable merci
Madame Cohen
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est un
rappel au règlement au titre de
l'article 44 je remercie madame la
présidente des affaires sociales enfin
de réunir la commission des affaires
sociales parce que pendant tout l'examen
on a eu beau faire des rappels au
règlement nous n'avons pas eu ce
privilège donc il y a je crois que la
démocratie a été pas mal bafouée et
franchement cette page d'amendements
sans suspension de séance à l'origine et
à nous laisser gracieusement lire en
nous disant qu'il n'y avait pas de
modification je trouve quand même que là
si les droits des parlementaires ne sont
pas bafoués alors je ne sais plus
comment on peut appeler donc la quelques
minutes
grappiller grâce à la générosité de la
présidente on accepte mais franchement
je voulais faire ce rappel au règlement
en mon nom et au nom de mon groupe parce
que là mes chers collègues j'attire
votre attention sur la façon dont les
parlementaires et notamment de
l'opposition sont traité S et c'est une
remise en cause du parlementarisme
je vais suspendre pour permettre la
réunion de la commission madame pour une
dizaine de minutes
et on s'est donc reprise
je vais interroger la commission sur son
avis
sur l'amendement du Gouvernement merci
monsieur le Président donc la commission
des affaires sociales du Sénat s'est
réunie je voudrais dire que la vie est
favorable mais je voudrais comment vous
faire part d'un certain nombre de
réflexion que je me suis faite à la
suite de cette interruption je pense que
on a manqué de méthode par rapport à
cette présentation et j'en prends ma
part j'en prends ma part mais je pense
messieurs les ministres qu'on aurait dû
déjà avoir après
les les amendements qui ont été votés au
Sénat un premier tableau pour justement
informer nos collègues de l'ensemble des
traductions des prises de décision du
Sénat et puis ensuite je voudrais dire
aussi que apporter un amendement qui
comporte autant de pages c'est vrai que
c'est peu imaginable de pouvoir les lire
en quelques minutes alors que finalement
il y a qu'une ligne budgétaire qui
change et donc il faut qu'on trouve des
méthodes différentes parce que arrivé
sur un texte aussi important sur en
définitive un amendement qui est posé là
quelques minutes avant finalement le
vote final j'ai trouvé que la méthode
était effectivement contestable très
contestable et je vous en fais pas merci
merci
avant de passer aux explications de
votre sur l'ensemble je vais mettre au
voie c'est amendement
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
une abstention
donc amendement était adopté nous allons
passer aux explications de votre des
groupes je rappelle la raison d'un
orateur par groupe tout d'abord madame
la présidente Catherine de roche pour le
groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
rapporteur pour avis chers collègues la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
déroulée hier a marqué une étape
importante dans le parcours d'un texte
qui apprend un examen tronqué à
l'Assemblée nationale suivie d'un longue
examen au Sénat qui la conduit à plus
que doublé de volume à poursuivi le
cheminement ordinaire de la procédure
parlementaire
réunie pendant plus de 8h30 la
commission mixte paritaire a procédé à
une revue attentive de tous les articles
au fil notamment des différentes
propositions de suppression
nos collègues députés empêchait de
débattre en première lecture du recul de
l'âge légal des carrières longues ou
encore des équilibres financiers du
texte ont cette fois pu y procéder
permettant aux différentes sensibilités
de s'exprimer avant de passer au vote
cela a été rappelé à de nombreuses
reprises mais le Sénat soucieux de la
pérennité de notre modèle social et de
notre capacité collective en faire
bénéficier les générations futures
portent cette réforme de longue date les
évolutions démographiques et sociales
nous y oblige alors que l'émergence de
besoins sociaux accrus liés au
vieillissement à la santé ou encore à la
nécessité d'intervenir dans notre
jeunesse et dans l'avenir de notre pays
ne nous permet pas de nous permettent
pas de dégager des marches
supplémentaires pour le financement des
retraites
comme je l'indiquais dans la discussion
générale notre choix de consacrer une
part très importante de notre richesse
nationale aux retraites relèvent d'un
choix implicite qui ne revient
aujourd'hui de clarifier d'interroger de
discuter une part des gains d'espérance
de vie qui se poursuivent doit dès lors
être mobilisé pour le bien commun et la
consolidation du financement des
retraites deux autres éléments plaident
dans ce sens d'une part c'est que ça
génère d'aujourd'hui n'ont que peut
avoir avec leurs aînés des années 50 qui
partaient pourtant la retraite à 65 ans
et pour peu de temps d'autre part notre
système de retraite s'enrichit au fil du
temps de dispositifs de solidarité qui
atténue les inégalités de carrière et
corrigent les effets des règles
générales pour les publics les plus
vulnérables pour des raisons de santé de
carrière ou de revenus c'est pourquoi la
présente réforme pèse beaucoup moins que
les précédentes sur les publics fragiles
examen au Sénat a permis de renforcer
cette tendance nous avons voulu prendre
en considération la situation de ceux
qui ne peuvent travailler plus longtemps
parce qu'ils ont commencé tôt parce
qu'ils sont mauvaises santé ou parce que
leur fin de carrière manque de
perspective au-delà des atténuations des
effets de la réforme le texte porte des
avancées pour les apprentis les
stagiaires les étudiants ou les élus
locaux il s'inscrit dans une tendance
jamais démentie d'élargissement et
d'enrichissement de notre système social
au total le texte issu de la CMP propose
une réforme qui garantit l'avenir notre
système de retraite sans toutefois faire
peser l'effort sur ceux qui ne
pourraient le supporter c'est pourquoi
le groupe les républicains invite le
Sénat voter ce texte et apprendre ses
responsabilités avec courage comme il
l'a fait de manière constante nous
sommes conscients que ce texte marque
une étape et qu'il doit s'accompagner de
changements profonds dans la prise en
les salariés les plus âgés dans une
économie en pénurie de main d'oeuvre il
est évident qu'ils ont toutes leurs
places ce chantier avant tout celui des
entreprises et des partenaires sociaux
avant d'être celui de la loi néanmoins
si des changements législatifs s'avèrent
nécessaire nous répondrons présents
comme nous l'avons fait sur la santé au
travail sur l'assurance chômage et sur
toutes les réformes affectant le
fonctionnement du marché du travail la
retraite ne s'arrête le seul horizon
pour les jeunes qui ont dit cela toute
leur vie à construire je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente
maintenant la parole à notre collègue
Colette mélo pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoires
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur madame
la Présidente de la Commission mes chers
collègues plus de 100 heures de débats
au sida plusieurs milliers d'amendements
examinés 10 jours de discussion enfin
nous y sommes enfin ce PLFSS trouve une
issue la commission mixte paritaire
s'est réunie hier nous devons désormais
voter le texte qui en résulte c'est
pourquoi je le dis d'emblée notre groupe
votera pour cette réforme des retraites
notre objectif n'est pas de vendre du
rêve aux Français mais bien de fonder la
politique sur la réalité cette réalité
elle est limpide il y avait quatre
actifs pour un retraité dans les années
60 trois cotisants pour un retraité dans
les années 70 en 2023 ils sont 1,7 pour
un cotisant face à ce constat qui peut
croire que notre modèle social en l'état
et pérenne
il ne l'est pas le gouvernement se
devait d'agir le choix était binaire
augmenter les prélèvements c'était
pénaliser le pouvoir d'achat des
Français dans un contexte déjà difficile
augmenter le temps de travail des
Français rester donc la seule solution
réaliste alors que l'espérance de vie
progresse encore cela participe à sauver
notre régime par répartition et à
préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
Français nous saluons ainsi le report de
l'âge légal de deux ans il s'agit d'une
nécessité pour l'équilibre de notre
système nous regrettons toutefois que
l'ajout d'une dose de capitalisation
collective dans notre système par
répartition n'est pas été retenu il nous
faudra à l'avenir réfléchir à cette
question si de nombreux Français se sont
inquiétés de certains aspects de cette
réforme notamment sur les carrières
longues la commission mixte paritaire
est parvenue à trouver une solution à ce
sujet le groupe Les Indépendants avaient
choisi lors des débats de porter un
amendement favorisant les carrières
longues idées par de nombreuses
sénateurs nous nous réjouissons donc que
le dispositif adopté permettent à tous
ceux et en cotisés au moins cinq
trimestres avant 21 ans de partir plus
tôt sans avoir à cotiser plus de 43 à
nuités le coût est important de l'ordre
de 700 millions d'euros venant de le
voir à l'horizon 2030 mais cette mesure
a le mérite de donner plus de lisibilité
à la réforme et dans garantir l'équité
c'est la preuve que le compromis le
consensus sont possibles par ailleurs ce
texte contient plusieurs mesures de
justice sociale les régimes spéciaux
auraient été avaient été conçus à des
périodes où les circonstances l'imposer
en raison de mauvaises conditions de
travail de nombreux progrès ont été
faits en la matière ce qui justifie la
suppression progressive des régimes
spéciaux le régime général apparaît
désormais plus juste pour l'ensemble des
Français nous saluons donc le maintien
de cet article par la CMP
nous saluons également la surcante alors
jusqu'à 5% pour les maires de famille
ayant réalisé une carrière complète
c'était une nécessité elle vient combler
un manque elle rend hommage à ses femmes
qui tout en travaillant pour subvenir
aux besoins de leur famille participent
activement à l'éducation de leurs
enfants il est d'ailleurs juste d'avoir
étendu aux professions libérales la
majoration de 10% de la pension à partir
du troisième enfant tout comme il est
juste d'avoir intégré les indemnités
journalières de maternité dans le calcul
de la pension nous nous réjouissons de
l'adoption de l'assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants qui va bénéficier après
de 40000 personnes par an c'est un
dispositif que nous soutenons et qui va
dans le bon sens même si certains
d'entre nous auraient souhaité qu'il
aille plus loin
de plus la prise en compte d'une
majoration de trimestres bénéfices des
pompiers volontaires représentent une
avancée tout à fait justifiée que nous
avions nous-mêmes défendu
sceptique sur le CDI senior qui a été
proposé nous sommes rassurés de
constater qu'il a été maintenu mais à
titre expérimental cela permettra d'en
juger l'efficacité avant de généraliser
éventuellement le dispositif dans le
même registre l'index senior peut être
Natoo nous ne doutons pas que cette
politique volontariste en faveur de
l'emploi des seniors trouvera son
aboutissement dans la future loi travail
les échanges entre les générations sont
une richesse pour les entreprises et
doivent être encouragés ainsi toutes ces
mesures cette réforme avec toutes ces
mesures cette réforme des retraites est
juste et s'inscrit dans le pacte social
français elle est un moyen de garantir
la pérennité de notre système de
retraite ce qui est indispensable le
groupe Les Indépendants votera
l'adoption de ce texte je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègues
[Applaudissements]
pour expliquer
pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègue le texte soumis au vote du
Parlement aujourd'hui et le fruit d'une
CMP son suspense où l'opposition a pris
connaissance du résultat des
réaménagements à la marge pour assurer
les votes de la droite dans les deux
chambres négocier à la monte avec le
gouvernement dans le cadre d'un budget à
louer aux mesures d'atténuation de la
brutalité de la réforme nous avons
assisté au compromis final croquant une
mesure contre une autre tout en
préservant la philosophie générale
travaillait plus par le report de l'âge
ouvrant droit à la retraite de 62 à 64
ans
assis le CDI senior du Sénat a été
contenue à une expérimentation pour
libérer quelques centaines de millions
pour un meilleur calibrage des carrières
longues conditionnant quelques votes à
l'Assemblée nationale nous soutenons pas
la première mesure et constatant que la
seconde n'a pas atteint son but nous
remarquons néanmoins que la droite
sénatoriale a consentir abandonné une
partie de ses amendements et remaniement
du texte pour éviter un 49,3 à
l'Assemblée nationale après avoir
consenti au 44 3 au Sénat
défendus depuis plusieurs années cette
réforme valait bien quelques sacrifices
du rôle du Parlement le coeur de la
réforme est inchangé quant à son
injustice et sa brutalité comme sa
dimension productiviste puisque son
impact annoncé a été évalué au gains
d'un point de PIB un point de PIB au
prix de pour beaucoup d'un prolongement
du sas de précarité de pauvreté d'une
explosion des arrêts maladie de longue
durée du chômage du basculement dans les
minimes soit un coût social inédit une
fracture sociale approfondie
ignorée par les partisans de la réforme
qui n'ont rien d'autre à proposer qu'un
index non contraignant une
expérimentation CDI fin de carrière
prétexte de nouvelles exonération et une
boude surcote contre la liberté de
partir à la retraite
un point de PIB V vanter à coups de
mensonges sur les 1200 euros et de
marchandages entre les droites et le
gouvernement pour troquer je l'ai dit
une mesure d'atténuation contre une
autre dans l'objectif toujours partagé
de réaliser l'économie des dépenses
sociales qui financera infinies les
nouvelles belles impôts des plus
fortunés
un point de PIB en imposant une
augmentation contrainte de l'offre de
travail
en imposant la concurrence entre
travailleurs pour faire pression sur les
salaires après avoir dérégulé le marché
du travail permis la dégradation des
conditions de travail et voter une
restriction des droits au chômage
un point de PIB à contre-courant
ignorant les transformations sociétales
et sociales en cours la crise de
l'attractivité les vagues de démission
et le ras de bold face à la
subordination salariale au manque
d'autonomie dans le travail et de sens
au travail un point de pays B que vous
gravillez encore sur le travail
aggravant le partage inégal des
richesses alors que la ponction des
dividendes explose et capte justement de
plus en plus de points de PIB un point
de PIB parce que vous ignorez la
diversité et l'utilité des services non
marchands et le logiciel nouveau pour
relever les défis sociaux et climatiques
de notre siècle
un point de PIB contre les
préconisations du GIEC arrachées à la
terre alors que la France dépasse déjà 6
des 9 limites planétaires et alors que
sa grave les inégalités de patrimoine
inconscillables avec la bifurcation
écologique
un point de PIB parce que vous êtes
prisonnier d'un logiciel productiviste
incapable d'imaginer une prospérité sans
croissance ou serait possible et même
nécessaire une réduction du temps de
travail
un point de PIB enfin on bafouant les
corps intermédiaires acteurs
représentatif de la démocratie sociale
moderne en brutalisant le Parlement en
ignorant le refus radical du peuple
français de cette réforme en l'imposant
comme si ce n'était qu'un mauvais moment
à passer vous vous trompez votre refus
de l'alternative à cet impact à savoir
le recours au référendum et de nouveau
un avis de faiblesse retirez votre
projet ou soumettez-le au référendum car
vous n'avez pas de mandat du peuple
français pour cette réforme le groupe le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire votera compte bien entendu
mais vous appelle monsieur le ministre à
la responsabilité et on retrait de votre
réforme je vous remercie merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Xavier yakovénie pour le gros du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame et monsieur le
rapporteur madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues nous arrivons au terme
de ce débat sur la réforme des retraites
74 heures de débat à l'Assemblée 109 au
Sénat 9h en commission mix paritaire
personne ne pourra nier le fait que nous
avons eu le temps de débattre sur le
fond certains ont remis même en cause la
légitimité des outils de notre
Constitution ou de notre règlement
intérieur mais l'obstruction d'une
minorité n'aura pas empêché la majorité
d'entre nous qui souhaitons améliorer le
texte et de faire pourquoi ce pourquoi
nous sommes élus c'est-à-dire voter la
loi
et je me félicite mes chers collègues
que nous ayons abouti à ce sur ce texte
car c'est le fruit d'un travail
parlementaire le fruit de travail de
toutes les sensibilités de notre chambre
en trouvant un compromis nous avons
répondu à la nécessité d'équilibrer
notre système de retraite tout en
assurant des droits et des progrès
nouveaux
le travail est au coeur de cette réforme
mais vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre alors que certains considèrent
que le travail est une contrainte et une
soumission un système qui exploite les
citoyens nous nous voyons dans le
travail le fait que celui-ci donne un
rôle et une place dans la société qui
crée du lien social et qui offre les
conditions d'émancipation et de dignité
parce que oui mes chers collègues
beaucoup de nos concitoyens
s'épanouissent dans leur vie active et
ils y trouvent un sens et une place dans
notre société et il n'y a pas de déni
dans mes propos certains métiers sont
moins épanouis sans que d'autres
certains sont plus usants et plus
pénibles et il faut donc adapter notre
système à ses publics fragile et c'est
ce que nous avons fait dans ce projet de
loi
nous avons voulu accès notre travaux sur
des points qui sont essentiels qui sont
synonymes d'avancer de solidarité pour
les Françaises et les Français tout
d'abord on renforçant les droits
familiaux avec la création de la
surcotte sur les pour les mers qui
auraient travaillé une durée d'assurance
requise à 63 ans sur l'extension aux
professionnels professions libérales
pardon de la majoration de 10% de la
passion la pension à partir du troisième
enfant ou encore avec la prise en compte
du congé maternité nous avons aussi
souhaité après un débat en commission
mixparitaire garder la proposition de la
présidente billon sur la privation de
l'attribution de trimestres pour les
parents condamnés pour violence et
maltraitance à l'encontre de son enfant
ou encore la fixation d'un minimum de
deux trimestres de majoration au titre
de l'éducation des enfants au bénéfice
de la mer porté par la présidente
Rossignol protégeant de fait les femmes
nous avons souhaité soutenir les publics
les plus fragiles notamment avec la
version de pension pour les orphelins
avec des mesures spécifiques pour les
enfants porteurs de handicap ou la
revalorisation des retraites et de
l'ASPA à Mayotte portée par notre
collègue Tanny Mohamed Souali nous avons
porté également plusieurs mesures pour
rendre notre système plus juste avec une
meilleure prise en compte des carrières
hachées par le renforcement des droits à
la retraite pour les aidants pour
l'attribution de la durée d'assurance au
titre de l'éducation en cas de décès de
l'enfant par l'intégration des périodes
d'emploi des stagiaires et des apprentis
dans le calcul des droits à la retraite
et enfin la majoration pour la retraite
pour les sapeurs-pompiers mais aussi et
ça a fait longuement débats par
l'assouplissement du dispositif carrière
longue en ajoutant une barrière à 18 ans
et à 21 ans qui s'ajoute à celle
existante de 16 ans et 20 ans ainsi
qu'en supprimant le dispositif de la loi
Touraine imposant jusqu'à deux ans de
plus de la durée de cotisation
pardon de la durée de cotisation ce
ayant travaillé à partir de 16 ans plus
aucune personne ayant travaillé avant 21
ans ne sera obligé de aller plus loin
que la durée de cotisation de 43 à 8
cette réforme permettra également une
prise en compte de l'usure
professionnelle par l'élargissement de
l'accès aux comptes professionnels de
prévention et par la création d'un fond
inédit d'investissement d'un milliard
pour la prévention ce texte mes chers
collègues a été considérablement
enrichie la par la lecture du Sénat
renforçant ainsi le rôle de notre
chambre de la fabrique de la loi
notre système para répartition tout
entier et bien bâti sur la solidarité
solidarité intergénérationnelle entre
actif et retraité nous votons pour une
société plus solidaire prospère et
pérenne devant une réalité démographique
implacable monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez rappelé nous faisons le choix de
la responsabilité face aux déséquilibres
notre de nos finances publiques nous
faisons le choix du travail
confronté au risque d'une paupérisation
sociale nous faisons le choix de
l'équité parce que nous valoriserons
toujours le travail face à la taxation
excessive notre groupe votera en faveur
de ce texte et les conclusions de la CMP
je vous remercie merci
prenez la parole à notre collègue
Monique Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
vous avez la parole
messieurs les ministres madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales
madame monsieur le rapporteur
j'avais travaillé un texte
pour ma discussion générale comme nous
le faisons en règle générale
seulement voilà
je ne l'utiliserai pas
parce que j'ai entendu les propos des
ministres
parce que j'ai entendu d'autres propos
et donc finalement je n'utiliserai pas
ce que j'avais prévu je vous parlerai
plutôt avec mes tripes
monsieur le monsieur le ministre du soft
vous avez pris soin d'expliquer à quel
point le débat c'était mal passé dans
nos deux assemblées alors bien sûr vous
avez dit toujours en parlant du Sénat
que c'était dans une moindre mesure ici
mais vous avez quand même critiqué la
façon dont nous avait dont nous avons
travaillé or nous avons travaillé très
très sérieusement les oppositions comme
la majorité j'imagine on travaillait
très sérieusement on préparait leur
sujet pendant des semaines alors oui
alors oui monsieur le ministre nous
avons utilisé ce que nous pouvions
utiliser c'est-à-dire notre droit
d'amendement parce que si nous n'avions
pas utilisé notre droit d'amendement je
ne vois pas bien comment nous aurions pu
débattre de ce sujet vous aviez tout
fait en commençant par le choix du
véhicule législatif pour nous empêcher
d'aller au fond de ce sujet et de
débattre le plus longtemps possible vous
aviez tout fait pour réduire donc oui
nous avons rajouté des amendements parce
que nous voulions oui vous pousser
jusque dans vos retranchements et si
nous voulions faire ça c'est parce que
nous accompagnons le mouvement social et
ces millions de salariés qui ne veulent
pas du report de l'âge de la retraite
vous nous parlez
quant à vous monsieur le ministre Attal
comme d'habitude vous vous nous
promettez l'enfer comme d'habitude la
faillite l'enfer tout ça n'est pas
sérieux voilà nous savons qu'il y aura
effectivement peut-être
des déficits à l'aune de 13 milliards
d'euros dans quelques années et nous
nous avons proposé d'autres possibilités
pour combler ces déficits ça vous fait
beaucoup sourire mais je pense que les
salariés aujourd'hui n'auront pas envie
de rire quant à la CMP on nous dit la
CMP d'hier a permis de trouver un
compromis une CMP c'est une CMP tout le
monde ici c'est comment ça se passe et
de quoi il s'agit donc les compromis ils
n'ont pas été trouvés hier dans la
journée la CMP elle a duré parce qu'une
fois de plus nous vous avons obligé nous
avons contraint à aller sur tous les
articles mais tout était bouclé hier
matin et tout était bouclé non pas dans
l'intérêt des salariés tout était bouclé
dans l'intérêt du gouvernement et du
président de la République parce qu'en
fait
parce qu'en fait il s'agissait
décidément je vous le dis chers amis
c'est très rigolo ce que je veux dire ça
rit beaucoup sur les bancs et parce
qu'en fait tout ce qu'il fallait c'était
sauver la face tellement votre projet de
loi est mal engagé depuis des mois
tellement il est mal perçu par la
population donc la CMP d'hier c'était
pour sauver la face la réforme j'y viens
mais vous nous avez suffisamment entendu
nous ne voulons pas des 64 ans parce que
c'est 64 ans vont pénaliser ceux qui
travaillent depuis longtemps donc ceux
qui ont les métiers les plus difficiles
et ceux qui perçoivent les salaires les
moins élevés alors vous avez apporté des
mesures on va dire d'atténuation les
contrats seniors mais les contrats
seigneurs une fois de plus payés par
d'autres notamment si j'ai bien compris
maintenant plus ou moins la branche ATMP
les contrats seniors qui verront encore
faire des cadeaux aux entreprises comme
si on ne leur faisait pas assez comme si
maintenant le recrutement dans les
entreprises était seulement soumis aux
cadeaux fiscaux et sociaux qu'on leur
ferait
les surcottes pour les femmes les
surcottes pour les femmes alors là
franchement
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'expliquer
plusieurs fois qu'aujourd'hui une femme
qui arrive à 62 ans avec tous ces
trimestres qui décide de travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans à 10 % de surcotte là
elle décidera plus elle y sera obligée
et on lui donnera royalement 5% de
surcote
les petites pensions les petites
pensions mais qu'elle fiasco mais quelle
fiasco après nous avoir raconté que 2
millions de Français qui ont les plus
petites pensions verrez leur retraite
s'améliorer alors que nous savons que ce
n'est pas vrai quant aux carrière longue
quant aux carrière longue je suis désolé
de vous dire malgré tous vos efforts que
personne n'y comprend rien personne n'y
comprend rien nous espérons qu'un grand
nombre en bénéficiera parce
qu'effectivement parce qu'effectivement
l'objet de ce de ce texte c'est de
toucher à ceux qui travaillent déjà
depuis longtemps ma conclusion comment
allez-vous réparer ce pays que vous êtes
en train durablement de fracturer
je vais donner la parole à
notre collègue
Cathy a poursu poli pour le groupe
communiste
républicain citoyens et écologistes vous
avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président cher collègue sans
surprise la Commission mixparitaire a
trouvé un accord sur cette réforme des
retraites à 10 sur 14 vous avez voté les
64 ans quelle légitimité rien d'étonnant
puisque républicain
comment républicain centriste et
Renaissance sont favorables à
l'allongement de l'âge légal à 64 ans
nous allons examiner les conclusions de
la CMP sans la mise en ligne du rapport
mais bon sur les bords de la droite
pluriennes vous gêne rapport ou pas vous
voterez lors de cette scène payière
d'ailleurs à l'article 14 alors que
celle-ci était loin d'être terminée vous
avez sorti un communiqué annonçant une
CMP
conclusive il aura fallu moins de temps
en CMP pour dîner l'avenir de notre pays
qu'il n'en a fallu au Sénat pour déposer
un amendement de réécriture de l'article
qui a fait tomber 1300 amendements nous
n'oublions pas non plus que la majorité
présidentielle et la majorité
sénatoriale veulent imposer une réforme
à laquelle sont opposées 70% des
Français et 90% des actifs cette
minorité politique a décidé à une
majorité je le disais de 10 sur 14 en
commission mixte paritaire du sort de
notre avenir à la crise sociale et
environnementale le gouvernement les
droites parlementaires ont donc décidé
d'ajouter une crise parlementaire et une
crise démocratique vous imposez une
régression sociale en ayant recours aux
artifices de la Constitution et du
Règlement du Sénat depuis deux mois le
peuple vous dit non il était encore des
milliers dans la rue hier pour la 8e
fois pour refuser votre projet nous
avons dénoncé votre projet injuste
inefficace et impopulaire mais votre
obsession s'est transformée en aveugle
le texte issu de la CMP acte une réforme
profondément injuste qui va s'appliquer
dès le premier septembre et contrainte
des milliers de concitoyens de retarder
leur peau de départ en retraite de deux
ans le gouvernement a donc accepté le
contrat de fin de carrière des
républicains en 2006 un contrat du même
type avait été instauré pour un résultat
nul le gouvernement devrait mettre
autant d'énergie à lutter contre la
patronale aux cotisations sociales et
contre l'évasion fiscale les sommes
recouvraient permettraient de financer
notre système de retraite sans imposer
deux années supplémentaires de vie
brisés contrairement aux affirmations du
ministre Gabriel Attal l'équilibre du
système de retraite n'est nullement
garanti par cette réforme l'équilibre
est assuré par la baisse de la
subvention d'équilibre de l'État au
régime de retraite et notamment le gel
du point d'indice des fonctionnaires et
la réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
territoriaux et hospitalier votre dogme
libéral vous fait perdre la raison ce
sont les politiques d'austérité qui ont
entraîné le déséquilibre de notre
système de retraite je rappelle que le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
détails dans son rapport les mesures
d'économie sur la masse salariale
publique se traduisent par une
détérioration du solde du système de
retraite ce sont les choix faits par la
droite sous Nicolas Sarkozy qui
permettent aujourd'hui au parlementaire
les républicains d'exiger la
généralisation de la capitalisation dans
notre système par répartition le refus
de mettre un contribution les plus
riches le refus de mettre à contribution
les dividendes le refus d'élargir
l'assiette de cotisations démontent les
intérêts de ceux que vous protégez vous
avez même refusé l'augmentation de la
cotisation employeur pourtant proposée
par le Haut Commissariat au Plan pour
garantir la pérennité du système de
retraite vous faites passer les intérêts
boursier avant la prise en compte de la
pénibilité des inégalités salariales
entre les femmes et les hommes la
suppression des régimes spéciaux est une
vision éclairante de la manière dont
vous concevez la prise en compte de la
pénibilité des métiers en conclusion
nous avons assisté à un marché dupe
entre le gouvernement et les
républicains qui ont renoncé à leur
amendement sur les carrières longues et
la prise en compte des risques chimiques
vous portez un projet de classe contre
les travailleurs et les travailleurs la
fébrilité du pouvoir monte avec la
menace du
49,3 de plus en plus menaçant avec le
gouvernement vous pouvez utiliser tous
les coups de force anti-démocratique
comme vous l'avez fait ici vous ne
convaincraiez pas les français du bien
fondé de votre réforme qui vise à les
faire travailler jusque 64 ans bien au
contraire le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste
s'opposera jusqu'au bout à cette réforme
et soutiendra le mouvement social
merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Olivier Hainaut pour le groupe
de l'Union centriste
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame monsieur le les
rapporteur madame la Présidente de
commission chers collègues nous y voilà
nous abordons la toute dernière ligne
droite de ce texte sur la réforme des
retraites notre groupe Union centriste
votre âme majoritairement ce texte mes
premiers mots seront pour dire que nous
avons le Sénat la majorité sénatoriale
était à la hauteur de l'enjeu sourd à la
démagogie vous savez la démagogie je
vous écoutez chers collègues dont le
triomphe est passager les ruines
éternelles disaient Peggy
j'irai même plus plus loin le Sénat la
majorité sénatoriale a donné le la tel
un diapason sur ce texte l'occasion bien
sûr de saluer de remercier nos
rapporteur pour la qualité de leur
travail et leur connaissance du dossier
retraite ils l'ont démontré tout au long
de du débat de la CMP et puis encore à
l'instant en commission
sur le texte lui-même mes chers
collègues je persiste les signes il ne
mérite pas toute cette indignation qu'il
suscite il le justifie pas non plus un
enthousiasme démesuré ni le diable ni la
mer des réformes un texte et ce n'est
pas rien qui assure la survie de notre
régime par répartition et surtout un
texte qui évite à notre pays de
s'endetter pour payer ses retraites
souvent nous entendons dans cette
émission qu'il y a une bonne dette et
une mauvaise dette je partage cette
opinion s'endetter pour investir dans la
recherche dans les infrastructures bref
s'endetter pour l'avenir s'endetter pour
innover peut avoir une dimension
vertueuse mais sans d'été pour le
fonctionnement c'est irresponsable et
c'est compromettent l'avenir cela nous
est interdit d'ailleurs dans les
collectivités territoriales sous peine
d'être mis sous tutelle mais pour moi
pour nous s'endetter pour payer les
retraites c'est le comble de
l'irresponsabilité c'est une honte pour
les plus jeunes générations
cette affirmation toute simple donne
sens au vote de ce texte j'ai entendu
beaucoup parler chers collègues pendant
cette discussion et puis même à
l'instant et cette citation de
Shakespeare me revenait les mots ne
payent pas les dettes chers collègues
les mots ne payent pas les dettes ce
texte
[Musique]
donne de la solidité pour plusieurs
années à notre système de retraite par
répartition notons les avancées je vais
assez vite parce qu'elles ont été
abordés la question de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes la question de
l'emploi des seniors avec un dispositif
d'incitation des trimestres excusés du
peu pour les tuques les aidants les élus
qui gagnent moins de 1830 euros par mois
la pénibilité et puis les carrières
longues avec ses 43 ans mais alors
pourquoi ce texte avec ses avancées ce
texte qui au total concerne si Français
sur 10 et pas ceux dont les métiers sont
les plus pénibles pourquoi ce texte
suscite-t-il autant de tension nous y
voyons plusieurs causes notre système de
retraite est injuste mais c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il y a eu la réforme Touraine on
vous a peu entendu sur l'injustice du
système de retraite et donc ce système
de retraite est injuste il les moins à
l'issue de cette réforme mais il faudra
encore continuer à avancer vers plus de
justice une autre cause c'est que nous
attendons peut-être trop de réformes des
retraites une réforme des retraites ne
peut pas corriger toutes les injustices
de la société française de notre système
social et enfin et surtout la cause de
ces tensions pour notre groupe c'est le
manque de dialogue social et la crise du
paritarisme c'est selon nous la faute
originelle de l'exécutif d'avoir enjambé
les corps intermédiaires c'est pourquoi
nous appelons à l'ouverture d'une
conférence sociale après le vote de ce
texte les sujets sociaux sur la table
sont importants et nombreux le travail
valeur contrainte on en a débattu tout
au long de de ces derniers jours la
rémunération des salariés le cadre de
gestion de l'assurance chômage l'emploi
des seniors et encore beaucoup d'autres
la santé le logement sur toutes ces
questions la société française a besoin
et cet apaisement passe par la
paritarisme et a dit la langue sociale
refonder et rénovée voilà mes chers
collègues pour conclure je veux vous
faire partager mon sentiment différent
de ce que j'ai entendu à l'instant
sentiment d'avoir vécu un beau moment
par le mental un vrai moment
parlementaire ici au Sénat nous avons
fait honneur mes chers collègues au Bica
Maryse le Sénat représente les
territoires et c'est son honneur le
Sénat représente les territoires et
c'est son honneur mais nous avons
apporté la réponse la plus forte à ceux
qui nous ont parfois caricaturés en
Bundes rate nous sommes un parlement de
plein droit et surtout un pilier de la
République vive le Sénat vive la
république mes chers collègues je vous
remercie merci
je vais donner la parole
un sénateur appartenant à la Réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe monsieur
Stéphane Ravier
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues aujourd'hui
nous avons un vote crucial pour éviter
d'infliger de nouveaux sacrifices à nos
compatriotes et mettre le gouvernement
assez responsabilités votre crucial en
vue de réconcilier la démocratie
parlementaire avec les Français vote
crucial pour la droite qui peut enfin
envoyer le message qu'elle n'est pas là
pour servir la soupe à Emmanuel Macron
votre crucial pour la gauche en vue
d'expier sa faute d'avoir appelé à voter
pour le candidat Macron en 2022 et
d'avoir voulu empêcher le vote du texte
une tenue parlementaire d'aussi mauvais
goût que sa tenue vestimentaire en
réalité
en réalité dois-je vous le rappeler mes
chers collègues nous sommes des hommes
et des femmes libres moi en tout cas je
le suis l'exécutif lui est piégé car
Bercy a promis cette réforme des
retraites à la Commission européenne
pour bénéficier du plan de relance et du
coup quoi qu'il en coûte il est obligé
de faire cette réforme désormais c'est
une réforme économique idéologique pas
une réforme sociale il la fera sans nous
en tout cas il la fera sans moi nous
voilà pieuse et point liés à Madame
vanderleyen et l'Union européenne alors
que notre participation nette à son
budget et de 10 milliards d'euros par an
en voilà des économies je ne dis pas à
la réalité problématique du système par
et partition il n'y a qu'un seul 15,7
actifs pour un retraité aujourd'hui
c'est vrai cependant ce n'est pas la
faute des Français si pour se plier aux
exigences de l'ultra-libéralisme les
gouvernements ont abandonnés depuis 30
ans notre tissu agricole et industriel à
une concurrence étrangère déloyale je
tends des millions de Français au
chômage et nous privant ainsi d'autant
de cotisants reporter l'âge de la de
départ à la retraite c'est demander plus
d'efforts aux Français pour s'éviter de
tailler dans les gisements d'économie
tabou car des économies il y en a à
faire sur la fraude sociale 20 à 30
milliards sur la fraude fiscale près de
40 milliards selon un rapport sénatorial
sur le recours au cabinet de conseils
2,5 milliards selon l'inspection
générale des finances sur la fraude
migratoire plusieurs dizaines de
milliards dans un pays où les
prélèvements obligatoires représentent
un record européen de 45% du PIB par
facilité par paresse par couardise
aucune réflexion n'est engagée par
l'État pour baisser les cotisations qui
pèsent sur notre croissance comme les
précédents le gouvernement actuel
préfère sacrifier les travailleurs et
les maires de famille plutôt que de
sacrifier son allégeance européiste en
engageant les réformes structurelles
nécessaires et urgente
c'est-à-dire revenir un état stratège
qui protège le présent et prévoit
l'avenir en soutenant l'industrie le
monde des paysans créer des emplois
qualifiés pour les plus jeunes engager
une politique familiale ambitieuse
encourageant la date qualité française
et exclusivement française
puisque le président fait le tour du
monde pour fuir la colère des Français
le Sénat doit lui envoyer un message
clair quand le président Macron prend
une cuite à Kinshasa ce n'est pas aux
Français à avoir la gueule de bois c'est
pourquoi mes chers collègues je vous
invite à refuser le grand déclassement
en faisant un bras d'honneur à cette
injuste projet de loi
la parole est maintenant au président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le gros du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame et Messieurs les
rapporteur mes chers collègues le
président la souligné samedi soir le
Sénat a consacré un peu plus de senteurs
de débats pour aller jusqu'au vote sur
l'ensemble du texte de la réforme des
retraites ce que le collègue de
l'Assemblée nationale n'ont pu faire
c'est pendant notre hémicycle aussi la
forme la trop souvent emporté sur le
fond la politesse en plus amendement
d'écrire à l'infini et petit livre vert
brandit très fréquemment toute la
palette les outils de l'obstruction
parlementaire a été utilisé
le Parlement ne sort pas grandi de cet
épisode la réforme héritée des débats
plus approfondie sur bien des aspects il
a fallu en passer par le 44 3 pour
pouvoir se penser à minima sur tous les
articles soyons lucide c'est une réforme
nous semble nécessaire car la logique
démographique depuis plusieurs décennies
menacent l'équilibre financiers de notre
régime de retraite c'est une évidence le
système a un grand défaut il ne supporte
pas une donnée pourtant heureuse celle
de l'allongement de l'espérance de vie
c'est une équation qu'il nous faut
résoudre tout en compte de certaines
situations tous les métiers ne se valent
pas c'est que certains peuvent faire que
64 ans d'autres ne peuvent pas le faire
car il y a exposition au risque car il y
a un accident de la vie car il n'y a pas
suffisamment d'offres d'emploi pour les
seniors pour parce qu'il y a des gens
qui connaissaient très tôt et pour
lesquels l'expression une retraite bien
méritée prend tout son sens
la sienne me paie qui s'est réunitaire à
a-t-elle réussi à trouver cet équilibre
entre nécessité et justice nos collègues
sont pas vus à l'accord c'est assez
clair les travaux de la commission
portent la marque du Sénat bien entendu
le fondement du texte le gouvernemental
demeure et dont le fameux article 7 sur
l'âge légal de départ ainsi que l'index
seniors qui avait été retenu par notre
assemblée nos collègues rapporteurs ont
exposé les principaux apports de
massemblée j'ai en y reviendrai pas si
c'est pour saluer les améliorations
concernant les carrières longues mais
aussi pour regretter le recul sur
l'usure professionnelle avec le retrait
du critère d'exposition aux agents
chimiques dangereux
ses collègues la balle sera cet
après-midi dans le camp de l'Assemblée
nationale en attendant je n'avais pas
caché les différentes sensibilités qui
existent au sein de mon groupe chacun a
voté jusqu'à présent c'est aussi
ambition il en sera de même aujourd'hui
tout au long des débats nous sommes
toujours rassemblés sur les nombreux
défis de la réforme la pénibilité les
carrières longues l'emploi des seniors
la compensation de l'engagement citoyen
bénévole ou encore la possibilité de
rachat de trimestre pour différents
profits une dizaine notamment
à quelques-unes de nos attentes je pense
aux jeunes à l'apprentissage aux
étudiants au travers handicapé aux
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires ou encore
aux femmes pour lesquelles des
aménagements ont été apportés ce qui
nous réunit aussi au RDSE c'est l'idée
que la solidarité une valeur
républicaine à laquelle nous sommes
fortement attachés continuent de guider
le régime par répartition que la France
a mis en place en 1945 et auquel nous
concitoyens restent très attachés
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
conformément l'article 42 alinéa 12 du
règlement
je vais mettre au voie l'ensemble du
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 dans la rédaction qui résulte du
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire modifiée par l'amendement du
Gouvernement en application de l'article
59 de notre règlement de scrutin public
ordinaire et de droit le scrutin sera
ouvert dans quelques instants
il est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin
votant 345
exprimé 3007 pour 183
contre 114 de Sénat à adopter
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente vous souhaitiez
dire un mot
oui pour préciser à mes collègues de la
commission des affaires sociales une
réunion en salle 216 car nous avons un
amendement sur la PPL watte Blade que
nous devons examiner tout à l'heure il
n'y avait pas d'amendement jusqu'ici
donc nous avions annulé la commission
mais il y a un amendement du
Gouvernement donc réunion salle 206 je
vais mes chers collègues
suspendre la séance ce quelques instants
pour permettre à chacun
s'installer pour l'examen du prochain
point l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendue pour cinq minutes